[Música]
yo sé que estamos en él hemos pensado
uno de los años más violentos de la
historia moderna de méxico
y hablar de la palabra mafia es algo
delicado y también en el contexto
político en el que estamos en el que los
políticos han logrado con éxito
dividirnos hablar de esta palabra desde
el campo y ante esto me encanta esta
frase de confucio que dice no condenas a
la oscuridad es mejor enciende una luz y
básicamente esa es la idea de este
plática hablarles de otro concepto un
concepto positivo de lo que puede
significar la palabra mafia
y porque la filosofía del cangrejo es
cosa del pasado
así algunos años después de salir de la
universidad entré a trabajar a una
empresa en una empresa de calzado el
trabajo que me encantaba y un par de
amigos hicieron por allí una empresa con
negocios en internet y les empezó muy
bien invitaban a trabajar con ellos dije
negocio por internet suena muy
interesante dije bueno sigo en tránsito
quiero entrar bien y el dinero que hoy
ahorrado lo gaste en ir a esta región en
el norte de california que se conoce
como silicon valley donde en esa misma
región encuentras empresas como google y
empresas como twitter empresas como
youtube y varias de estas empresas que
están literalmente revolucionando el
mundo y al ir este lugar me di cuenta
que era mucho más allá que sólo 12
internet era un cambio filosófico el que
estábamos viviendo y el concepto de el
error era completamente distinto el
concepto de las ideas de colaborar con
la ciudad será completamente distinto y
una de las cosas que más me encantó de
ésta
pero ver que antes era méxico y aunque
pareciera como algo muy lejano en
realidad sigue midiendo muchos
compatriotas allá y en realidad nos
parecemos mucho y hay muchas cosas que
podemos aprender de esto uno de los
conceptos más importantes es cuando
vemos a alguien como steve jobs como el
hermoso como mark zuckerber pensamos que
hay el genio que se le ocurre todo el
tiempo las grandes ideas y todos los
demás son como minions que hacen justo
lo que lo que hice y todo sale perfecto
pero en realidad es muy distinto es un
grupo de personas que se apoyan que van
alineados a la misma visión y creo que
el mejor ejemplo de esto es la pei para
el marketing
justo es un término que los medios en
esta región luego usando una manera
positiva y ese mono eran dos empresas
que eran competencias se empezaron a
ayudar para transformar el sistema de
pagos y crear esta empresa en paypal y
lo interesante visto es que no sólo
venden la empresa en más de un billón de
dólares a ebay sino que después de eso
se empezaron a ayudar
ellos hicieron youtube uno de ellos fue
el primer inversionista de facebook otro
de ellos es nada más y nada menos que
los moscos otro es el fundador de
linkedin y varias empresas más y han
logrado lo que en deber llama como el
efecto multiplicador donde introduce se
apoyan generan un gran efecto cambian al
mundo y después con ese éxito ese
conocimiento ese dinero siguen haciendo
más efectos siguen invirtiendo creando
más empresas y apoyando y literalmente
en cambiando el mundo
seguramente ustedes van a decir oye pero
estos estados unidos
o sea como que tiene que ver con
nosotros suena muy lejos que ejemplo
podría haber de algo más cercano y creo
que es la magia el cine mexicano los
últimos seis años han ganado cinco
mexicanos han ganado ellos tres han
ganado con los mejores directores han
logrado romper récords con y así
devolver 500 camarón y ningún otro
americano ha logrado casos como chivo
lubezki que ha ganado tres años seguidos
como mejor fotógrafo y por qué porque se
han ayudado han entendido el valor de
ayudarse y también han entendido el
valor de pensar diferente el valor de
complementarse y todo este tipo de
concepto ahora sé que con esto ustedes
me pueden decir bueno ellos siguen
estando en hollywood sigue siendo eeuu
cómo aplicamos eso en méxico para hacer
un cambio verdadero y creo que el mejor
ejemplo de esto lo vemos
entendiendo que la filosofía del
cangrejo ya es cosa del pasado con lo
que pasó con los temblores del 19
septiembre esos dos casos esos momentos
donde de repente los mexicanos se
olvidaron de pensar primero en sí mismos
y era en que ayudó y había un
sentimiento de solidaridad bastante
fuerte que lograba hacer bastantes
cambios y logró mover a muchísima gente
para salvar vidas y para lograr generar
un gran impacto esta es la prueba de que
si podemos trabajar en equipo de que si
podemos hacer cosas fuertes si nos
organizamos
y aquí no los aprendizajes es si hay un
gran sueño estamos bajo presión o pasó
un gran reto que nos lleva a una cierta
crisis eso no es fuerza o nos va a
forzar a trabajar en equipo
y que podría pasar de esto en el futuro
actualmente me dedico a temas de
innovación y básicamente y llevo varios
años trabajando en una en una comunidad
que surge dentro de la de la nasa que se
llama silveti university y de ahí surge
un grupo que se dedica a estudiar qué
tiene en común lo que llaman
organizaciones exponenciales aquellas
empresas cómo ver cómo vivían como
wikipedia o todo este tipo de empresas
que están transformando el mundo y una
de las cosas que se ha visto con todo
este tipo de cosas es que cuando formas
grupos y los pones a resolver problemas
pasa magia uno de los puntos muy
interesantes que nos va a poner en este
tema muy interesante es en retos que
estamos viviendo ahorita es que por un
lado estamos solo en el inicio de la era
digital según toda esta comunidad de
futuristas lo que decimos es actualmente
hay un poco más
aparatos por habitante en la tierra
conectados a internet sin embargo para
el 2030 va a ver más de 110 aparatos por
habitante en la tierra es decir
podríamos decir que llevamos más menos
30 años de la era digital sin embargo
bajo esta métrica sólo estamos entre el
2 y el 3 por ciento la digital de lo que
se espera para el 2030 y lo interesante
de esto es que tenemos una serie de
instituciones que se están quedando
atrás que son muy obsoletas tenemos un
sistema educativo y esto sí que es
delicado haciendo en una universidad yo
creo que es importante tenemos un
sistema educativo del siglo 18
pretendiendo prepararnos para el siglo
21 que nos prepara más para 1980 que
para el 2030 tenemos un sistema de
gobierno
basado en la velocidad en cuando la
información se movía a la velocidad del
caballo no a la velocidad un tweet y a
nivel mundial sólo aproximadamente el 20
por ciento de la gente aprueba su
gobierno no importa si es un moderno
izquierda a un gobierno derecha y esto
por qué está pasando porque tenemos
sistema un sistema de gobierno de hace
siglos
pretendiendo solucionar problemas del
siglo 21 es obsoleto hay que hacer un
gran cambio de raíz y el tema económico
hay toda una serie de estructuras y
empresas que tienen un modelo
viejo obsoleto que de repente llegan al
siglo 21 una serie de empresas nuevas
como youtube como debía mí y como
wikipedia y todas este tipo empresas que
tienen un modelo de negocio
completamente diferente y cambian las
cosas y las empresas tradicionales les
cuesta mucho trabajo adecuarse y eso es
un gran reto es un gran reto que les va
a tocar vivir a todos ustedes ya no es
como antes como en la vida de tus
abuelos era la vida de tus padres iba a
ser tu vida a ustedes ya todos nosotros
nos va a tocar reinventarnos una y otra
vez en los próximos décadas y esto de
alguna forma es una cierta tensión es
una cierta crisis pero también es una
gran oportunidad y la forma de resolver
esto es trabajar en equipo ahora más que
nunca más importante trabajar en equipo
y uno de los puntos también muy
importantes con esto es
nada de esto va a ser
va a valer la pena si no logramos
resolver algunos de los problemas a los
que toda nuestra generación se está
enfrentando que es el calentamiento
global tenemos 12 años para lograr bajar
al menos el 50 por ciento además del 50
por ciento las emisiones de co2 si no
cambiamos como vivimos
no va a servir de nada pensar en el
trabajo de pensar en las empresas pensar
en el tema educativo si no hay un
planeta que sea estable para nosotros
como humanos tenemos sobre 12 años para
hacer un ajuste fuerte en cómo vivimos
como humanidad y otros retos fuertes a
los que nos estamos enfrentando es el
tema de la sexta extinción de las
especies se dice que diario por el
estilo de vida que llevamos como humanos
estamos generando la extinción de
algunos 200 especies a diario esto es
insostenible no podemos seguir con un
estilo de vida de esta forma pero la
respuesta está en ese grupo en ser
equipo si nos organizamos ahí es donde
pueden estar la solución y me gustaría
con esto invitarlos a un sueño que
imaginen un mundo donde exista un juego
social que mientras por un lado
adquieres las habilidades para pensar y
actuar de manera exponencial es decir
para poderte sumar al siglo 21
por otro lado estás ayudando a resolver
algunos de los mayores problemas de la 1
algunos de los mayores problemas del
mundo cualquier persona que me esté
escuchando con este que vibre con esto
lo invito a que quiere colaborar con
este proyecto es algo que estamos
convocando a una comunidad para llevar
esto a cabo y sé que es algo muy grande
es un sueño que puede sonar algo loco
pero me gustaría cerrar con esta frase
de marguerite que dice nunca dudes que
un pequeño grupo de ciudadanos
considerados pueda cambiar al mundo
verdaderamente eso es lo único que lo ha
logrado muchas gracias
[Música]